This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. Thomas Hood was a 19th century English poet known for his elegant, often melancholy verse. His 1826 poem, I Remember, I Remember, captures a feeling that is familiar to many adults, especially its wistful last lines. I remember, I remember, the fir trees dark and high. I used to think their slender tops were close against the sky. It was a childish ignorance, but now it is little joy to know I'm farther off from heaven than when I was a boy.
这是《Hidden Brain》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。托马斯·胡德是19世纪的一位英国诗人，以其优雅且常带忧郁的诗句而闻名。他1826年的诗作《我记得，我记得》捕捉到了许多成年人熟悉的一种感觉，尤其是那令人惆怅的最后几行。我记得，我记得，那深邃高耸的冷杉树。我曾以为它们纤细的树梢紧贴着天空。那是一种孩童般的无知，但如今，得知自己离天堂比儿时更遥远，已不再有丝毫的快乐。
Thomas Hood's poem gestures to the reality that as grown-ups, many of us lack the effortless sense of connection and awe that we felt as kids. Was that intimate bond with the universe merely an illusion of childhood, or a real measurable human capacity that we can access as grown-ups? Researchers are investigating the ways that we can preserve or revive the sense of being close to the sky that Thomas Hood so tenderly evoked. This week on Hidden Brain, we explore what it means to feel closer to heaven and the value of looking for transcendence in our busy, bustling lives. These days, we are encouraged and even exhorted to optimize every aspect of our lives, our bodies, our relationships, our productivity. But what about the parts of us that we're not? yearn for meaning, for understanding, for wisdom. Those aspects of ourselves are often ignored in our
托马斯·胡德的诗暗示了一个现实：作为成年人，我们许多人缺乏儿时那种毫不费力的连接感和敬畏感。那种与宇宙的亲密纽带仅仅是童年的幻觉，还是我们作为成年人也能触及的一种真实且可衡量的能力？研究人员正在探索我们如何能够保持或重拾那种托马斯·胡德温柔唤起的、与天空亲近的感觉。本周在《Hidden Brain》节目中，我们将探讨感觉离天堂更近意味着什么，以及在忙碌喧嚣的生活中寻找超越性的价值。如今，我们被鼓励甚至被敦促去优化生活的方方面面——我们的身体、人际关系、生产力。但那些我们无法优化的部分呢？那些对意义、理解和智慧的渴望。在对世俗回报的无休止追求中，我们自我的这些方面往往被忽视了。
tireless pursuit of worldly rewards. At Columbia University, psychologist Lisa Miller studies the science of transcendence. Lisa Miller, welcome to Hidden Brain. I'm so grateful to be here. I appreciate so much your show, the way you go deeper, the way you open up the double door in our life. So, Shankar, thank you for having me. Lisa, early on in your career as a psychologist, you treated a young woman named Ileana. Can you describe her for me and tell me what brought her into your clinic? Shankar, Ileana was only 12 years old.
在哥伦比亚大学，心理学家丽莎·米勒研究超越性的科学。丽莎·米勒，欢迎来到《Hidden Brain》。我非常高兴能来到这里。我非常欣赏你的节目，欣赏你深入挖掘的方式，以及你为我们生活打开那扇双重门的方式。所以，尚卡尔，谢谢你邀请我。丽莎，在你心理学家职业生涯的早期，你治疗过一位名叫伊莱亚娜的年轻女性。你能为我描述一下她，并告诉我她是因为什么来到你的诊所吗？尚卡尔，伊莱亚娜当时只有12岁。
She was in middle school. This was in New York. And she came in one day all by herself to the clinic. Generally, of course, young people are accompanied by a grandparent or a parent. Someone breaks them. This little girl hunched her arms wrapped tight. And when I invited her in to say, what has brought you here? The first thing she said was two men had walked into her father's store, her father owned a corner deli. Two men who he knew had walked into his store, robbed him and then taken his life. Her father was her son, her moon, her stars. She was devastated. Ileana was beyond bereft. She could barely move through the day.
她还在上初中。那是在纽约。有一天，她独自一人来到了诊所。通常情况下，年轻人当然是由祖父母或父母陪同的。有人带他们来。这个小女孩蜷缩着，双臂紧紧抱在一起。当我邀请她进来问她“是什么让你来到这里”时，她说的第一件事是：有两个男人走进了她父亲的店里，她父亲拥有一家街角熟食店。两个她父亲认识的男人走进店里，抢劫了他，然后夺走了他的生命。她的父亲是她的太阳、她的月亮、她的星星。她崩溃了。伊莱亚娜悲痛欲绝。她几乎无法度过每一天。
But equally, she was living in her new setting with her mother and her mother's mother. Both women had escaped themselves, very perilous and painful situations. And they were quite understandably guarded. it had yet to benefit from therapy. So in this setting, Ileana was really basically on a lockdown, a social lockdown. She wasn't allowed to go out and see friends. She wasn't allowed to go to the school of dance. She'd gone from being the apple of her father's eye to living in a very cold, restrictive
同样，她当时正和母亲以及外祖母生活在一个新的环境中。这两个女人都曾逃离过非常危险和痛苦的处境。她们理所当然地保持着警惕。她还没有从治疗中受益。所以在这个环境下，伊莱亚娜基本上处于一种封锁状态，一种社交封锁。她不被允许出去见朋友。她不被允许去舞蹈学校。她从父亲的掌上明珠变成了一个生活在非常寒冷、受限环境中的人。
environment. The treatment of the day would suggest help her renegotiate her condition, help her make sense of what had happened, addressed the trauma, the brutality of her father's death, and the wrongness, the moral and spiritual injury of her father's death. But all of the treatment as usual was not moving the needle.
当时的治疗建议是帮助她重新协商她的状况，帮助她理解所发生的事情，处理创伤、她父亲死亡的残酷性，以及她父亲死亡带来的错误、道德和精神上的伤害。但所有常规的治疗都没有起到作用。
I mean, you know, every day that a patient comes into the clinic, we do a quick assessment, one to ten, how are you? And she was never above a five. It was a four, it was a three, it was a five, never above a five. Well, one day she came absolutely skipping it, night and day. It was a whole different presentation clinically. It was as if the lights had been powered back on.
我的意思是，你知道，每天病人来到诊所，我们都会做一个快速评估，一到十分，你感觉如何？她从来没有超过五分。是四分，是三分，是五分，从来没有超过五分。嗯，有一天她绝对是蹦蹦跳跳地进来的，判若两人。从临床表现上看完全不同。就好像灯光重新被点亮了一样。
And I said, please, please come in, I'lliana. Tell me what is on your heart. What has happened? And she said, bouncing in her seat, joyfully, she looked me in the eye. She said, you're not going to believe this. You're not going to believe this. I was finally allowed to go to a dance. And I met a boy, and he was so polite, and he was so nice.
我说：“请进，伊莱亚娜。告诉我你心里有什么。发生了什么事？”她坐在椅子上欢快地跳动着，看着我的眼睛说：“你不会相信的，你不会相信的。我终于被允许去参加舞会了。我遇到了一个男孩，他非常有礼貌，非常友善。”
And we talked for 20 minutes, which is a long time in eighth grade. And you're not going to believe it. Guess what his name is. Ileana told Lisa that the boy she'd met had an extremely unusual name. And it turned out it was the same unusual name of her dead father. And she said, well, don't you see Dr. Miller? My father's watching over me. My father's protecting me.
“我们聊了20分钟，这在八年级来说是很长的时间。你绝对不会相信。猜猜他叫什么名字。”伊莱亚娜告诉丽莎，她遇到的那个男孩有一个非常不寻常的名字。结果发现，这和她已故父亲的名字一模一样。她说：“难道你看不出来吗，米勒医生？我父亲在守护着我。我父亲在保护我。”
My father's right here with me. I understand that shortly before she went on this dance, Ileana's grandmother had organized a traditional Dominican ceremony to honor her father. Describe the ceremony for me, Lisa. What happened there? Ileana's family had a beautiful tradition that was coming from the Dominican Republic, a blend of many faith traditions in which they honored the deceased, much as many, many traditions do. What was important to Ileana was that when they held the ceremony to honor her father with prayers, with candles, with photos,
“我父亲就在这里陪着我。”我了解到，在去参加舞会前不久，伊莱亚娜的祖母组织了一个传统的道明尼加仪式来纪念她的父亲。丽莎，请为我描述一下那个仪式。那里发生了什么？伊莱亚娜的家庭有一个来自多米尼加共和国的美丽传统，融合了许多信仰传统，他们像许多许多传统一样纪念逝者。对伊莱亚娜来说，重要的是当他们举行仪式，用祈祷、蜡烛和照片来纪念她父亲时，
Ileana, through the ceremony, knew her father's spirit was alive and real and in relationship to the family. So that shortly thereafter, when she met a boy at the dance who shared the very same name as her father, she had a depth of spiritual understanding that her father walks with her. She says, my father is looking after me. He is protecting me. I understand Lee said that you had a similar experience working on a psychiatric inpatient unit. Tell me about what life was like on that unit. and an intervention, an unusual intervention that you came up with at one point.
伊莱亚娜通过仪式知道她父亲的灵魂是鲜活的、真实的，并且与家庭保持着联系。所以在那之后不久，当她在舞会上遇到一个与她父亲同名的男孩时，她拥有了一种深刻的精神理解，即她父亲与她同行。她说：“我父亲在照顾我。他在保护我。”我了解到，丽莎，你在精神科住院部工作时也有过类似的经历。告诉我那个病房的生活是什么样的，以及你在某个时候想出的一个不同寻常的干预措施。
Shankar, I worked on an inpatient unit in Manhattan where so many of the patients suffered terribly. Some had recurrent, very deep major depression. Some struggled with addiction, others, schizophrenia. The time in which I happened to be an intern on the unit was the time of the Jewish holidays. This hospital happened to serve a great number of people who were. Jewish. As the holidays approached one morning in our community meeting, a gentleman raised his hand. He was someone who was known as very explosive as he struggled with bipolar. He'd become very angry, maybe toss a chair, yell and march out. So it was he, of all people who raised his hand in a full community meeting, 30 people in a circle under the flickering. lights, he raised his hand and said, what will we be doing for Yom Kippur? And the unit chief, a very nice man sort of looked at his foot and said, I'm sorry, we don't
尚卡尔，我在曼哈顿的一个住院部工作，那里的许多病人遭受着巨大的痛苦。有些人患有反复发作的、非常严重的重度抑郁症。有些人与成瘾作斗争，另一些人患有精神分裂症。我恰好在病房实习的时候正值犹太节日。这家医院恰好服务于大量犹太人。随着节日临近，一天早上在我们的社区会议上，一位先生举起了手。他是一个以脾气暴躁著称的人，因为他患有双相情感障碍。他会变得非常愤怒，可能会扔椅子、大喊大叫并冲出去。所以，在闪烁的灯光下，在30人围成的圆圈里，正是他举手说：“我们为赎罪日准备了什么？”而病房主任，一个非常好的人，看了看自己的脚说：“对不起，我们什么都没有。”拉比们要回家陪自己的家人。什么？什么？赎罪日什么都没有？他变得越来越不安，暴躁地扔了椅子，走出了房间。
have anything. The rabbis will be going home to their own families. What? What? Nothing for Yom Kippur, and he became more and more upset, explosive tossed the chair and walked out of the room. So I understand that you decided to arrange an informal Yom Kippur. service on the ward. Describe the scene for me. Well, I'm not a rabbi, but I did have at that time about two and a half decades of experience with Yom Kippur services. So I approached the unit chief who gave me permission and said, sure, if you want to come in on Yom Kippur, that's your decision. I found in a box in my apartment a beautiful weathered prayer book that had been my
所以我了解到，你决定在病房安排一个非正式的赎罪日仪式。为我描述一下那个场景。嗯，我不是拉比，但我当时有大约二十五年参加赎罪日仪式的经验。所以我找到了病房主任，他给了我许可，说：“当然，如果你想在赎罪日过来，那是你的决定。”我在公寓的一个盒子里找到了一本美丽的、饱经风霜的祈祷书，那是我祖母的。
grandmothers. That day, when I arrived to the U.S. it. The patients were all dressed beautifully. No hospital gowns or gurneys. Our so-called sanctuary was the back room, the kitchen, with its linoleum table and its fluorescent lights, but it felt sanctified. And there we were. There were four Jewish patients, and by their side, each had an aide who very graciously joined in our ceremony. As we started to move through the prayers, it was the gentleman who had been so explosive and so-called chaotic, who was holding the cadence of our prayers, who was doving, as we say, in Judaism, moving and swaying with his body and with the lyrical music of his voice, holding our collective prayer.
那天，当我到达病房时，病人们都穿得漂漂亮亮的。没有病号服或担架。我们所谓的“圣所”是后屋，也就是厨房，有油毡桌子和荧光灯，但它感觉被神圣化了。我们就坐在那里。有四位犹太病人，在他们身边，每人都有一个非常亲切地加入我们仪式的助手。当我们开始进行祈祷时，正是那位曾经非常暴躁、所谓的“混乱”的先生，他在掌控我们祈祷的节奏，他在“摇摆”（我们在犹太教中称之为dovening），随着他的身体和声音中抒情的音乐移动和摇摆，支撑着我们集体的祈祷。
He was far from chaotic. He was our spiritual leader and guide. the woman who had struggled so deeply with shame and guilt and depression perked up and said, I want to say something. I've always known that at Yom Kippur we can ask for forgiveness. But sitting here with all of you reading these prayers, I realized that we can be forgiven. All around the table, whatever had caged in their soul was superseded by the radiance in this moment of their spirit. It was extraordinary. And so I realized, Shankar, that something was happening in a spiritually grounded religious ceremony.
他远非混乱。他是我们的精神领袖和向导。那位一直深受羞耻、内疚和抑郁困扰的女士振作起来说：“我想说点什么。我一直知道在赎罪日我们可以请求宽恕。但坐在这里和你们所有人一起读这些祈祷文，我意识到我们可以被宽恕。”在桌子周围，无论是什么囚禁了他们的灵魂，都被他们精神中那一刻的光芒所取代。这太非凡了。所以我意识到，尚卡尔，在一种精神扎根的宗教仪式中，正在发生一些常规治疗中没有发生的事情。
that was not happening in treatment as usual. Once the word got out that Dr. Miller talks about spirituality, patients weren't even my own patients, would pull me over to the corner. One woman, who I happen to be Jewish, she happened to be Catholic, turned to me one day and said, Dr. Miller, I have some very heavy news. They will be sending me away upstate,
一旦米勒医生谈论灵性的消息传开，病人们——甚至不是我自己的病人——都会把我拉到角落里。一位女士，我碰巧是犹太人，她碰巧是天主教徒，有一天转向我说：“米勒医生，我有一些非常沉重的消息。他们要把我送到州北部去。”
which means no longer will she be living in Manhattan, and struggling through the revolving door of treatment, but is really being sent away. She said, will you come with me? I need to talk to you. And come with me and then walk down the hall, leave the offices, enter the kitchen,
这意味着她将不再住在曼哈顿，不再在治疗的旋转门中挣扎，而是真的被送走了。她说：“你会跟我来吗？我需要和你谈谈。”然后跟我走下大厅，离开办公室，进入厨房，
go way, way back into the pots and pans closet. And they're in the way, way back, Dr. Miller, will you pray with me before I'm sent upstate? We prayed she and her way. I prayed in my way. and what I saw was a great peace and a comfort coming over her. I didn't know how to pray her way, but I knew how to be with her in a common state of spiritual love and support. The next day I showed up, Shankar, her bed was made.
一直走到锅碗瓢盆储藏室的最深处。就在最深处，米勒医生，你能在被送往州北部之前和我一起祈祷吗？我们祈祷，她用她的方式，我用我的方式。我看到一种巨大的平静和安慰降临在她身上。我不知道如何用她的方式祈祷，但我知道如何在一种共同的精神爱与支持的状态中与她在一起。第二天我出现时，尚卡尔，她的床已经铺好了。
She was gone. I shared this story with one of the unit chiefs, who was a very good person and was, I think, trying to speak in my best interest. The unit chief said, what you did was beautiful. It was completely right. Don't ever tell anyone you did that. There was a sense that somehow spirituality doesn't belong here. Psychotherapy, mental health treatment is medical, so-called biological. What is this sort of airy, fairy, indeterminate, unmeasurable, otherly thing of spirituality?
她走了。我和其中一位病房主任分享了这个故事，他是一个非常好的人，我想他是在试图为我的最大利益着想。病房主任说：“你所做的是美丽的。这完全正确。但永远不要告诉任何人你做了这件事。”有一种感觉，似乎灵性不属于这里。心理治疗、心理健康治疗是医学的，所谓的生物学的。这种虚无缥缈、不确定、不可衡量、超然的灵性到底是什么？
Lisa, I understand that going home from work from this inpatient psychiatric unit, you noticed people in the subway. Now, these people were not clinically ill, but you felt that in their own way, they were also not healthy? Shankar, once we see in its intense, most grueling form mental illness, whether it's a deep depression or profound anxiety, as a therapist, it's then very easy to eyeball the subway, be at a dinner party, and see a whiff of that depression. or anxiety. So I left the inpatient unit and just about every day I'd ride home on the subway and see on people's faces and in their countenance what weighs on them. But one day, Shankar, I saw a gentleman whose eyes were bright like the sun. He wasn't smiling across his mouth, but there was a joy through him. He was an Orthodox Jew. probably Hibabad, and I could see that he was davening. He was praying right there on the subway.
丽莎，我了解到，从这个精神科住院部下班回家时，你注意到了地铁里的人。现在，这些人并没有临床上的疾病，但你觉得他们以自己的方式也不健康？尚卡尔，一旦我们以最强烈、最艰苦的形式看到了精神疾病，无论是深度抑郁还是严重的焦虑，作为一名治疗师，在地铁里观察，或者在晚宴上，就很容易看到那种抑郁或焦虑的蛛丝马迹。所以我离开了住院部，几乎每天我都会坐地铁回家，在人们的脸上和神情中看到压在他们心头的东西。但有一天，尚卡尔，我看到一位先生，他的眼睛像太阳一样明亮。他没有咧嘴笑，但有一种喜悦贯穿他全身。他是一位正统犹太教徒，可能是哈巴德派的，我能看出他在祈祷。他就在地铁上祈祷。
I felt the illumination, I felt the joy that I'd seen in the patients on the inpatient unit during our Yom Kippur service. And in this sort of struggle of more suffering than we really need to have in our lives on the subway, in a restaurant, in the coffee shop, I saw what was equal and opposite to the suffering, and it was the illumination of spiritual awareness and connection. I understand Lee said that in your own personal life, you and your partner had occasion to examine what you yourselves were doing. You had been focused on getting good educations and launching your careers, and from the outside, anyone could look at your lives and say, you know, here's a couple that's really
我感受到了那种光芒，感受到了我在赎罪日仪式期间在住院部病人身上看到的喜悦。在这种比我们生活中真正需要的更多的痛苦挣扎中，在地铁里、在餐馆里、在咖啡店里，我看到了与痛苦相等且相反的东西，那就是精神觉知和连接的光芒。我了解到，丽莎，在你的个人生活中，你和你的伴侣也有机会审视你们自己正在做的事情。你们一直专注于接受良好的教育和开启职业生涯，从外部看，任何人都可以看着你们的生活说：“你知道，这是一对真正成功的夫妇。”
made it. But I understand that from time to time you would look at each other and ask, is this really all there is? After years and years of hard work, my husband and I, for years and years, he had gone to law school and then worked in a law firm. I had gotten my PhD and then worked in clinical and research settings. We worked, you know, not 60 hours a week, probably more. We were more like the 70, 80 hour a week type. Driven by good things, we weren't overly obsessed with money. We were driven by the purpose of our work, the mission of our work.
但我了解到，你们不时会看着对方问：“这真的是全部吗？”经过多年的努力工作，我和我丈夫，多年来，他上了法学院，然后在律师事务所工作。我拿到了博士学位，然后在临床和研究环境中工作。我们工作，你知道，不是每周60小时，可能更多。我们更像是每周70、80小时的那种人。被美好的事物所驱动，我们并没有过度沉迷于金钱。我们被工作的目的、工作的使命所驱动。
But I'd say that there was a lopsidedness. We were getting a little narrow in our focus. And the people we loved very much who were so kind we could turn to in a moment of loss or pain, good friends, lived in the same culture with us. So our dinner parties would have a lot of talk about, you know, well, once I make partner or if we, We can move over from 2nd Avenue to Lexington or, you know, there's a promotion coming up or I'm moving from a two to a three bedroom. There was sort of almost a low-grade monopoly game going on that was narrowly achievement-oriented. And it felt empty as a tin. So, Lisa, there is a clinical term called dysdemia.
但我会说有一种失衡。我们的关注点变得有点狭窄了。我们非常爱的人，那些非常善良、我们在失去或痛苦时可以求助的人，好朋友，和我们生活在同一种文化中。所以我们的晚宴会有很多关于“嗯，一旦我成为合伙人，或者如果我们能从第二大道搬到列克星敦，或者，你知道，有一个晋升机会，或者我正从两居室搬到三居室”的谈话。有一种几乎是低级的“大富翁”游戏在进行，它是狭隘的成就导向的。它感觉像锡罐一样空洞。所以，丽莎，有一个临床术语叫“心境恶劣”（dysthymia）。
What does it mean? DeSymia is a low-grade, nagging, haunting, haunties. sort of like a milk toast gray depression. It's a dissatisfaction and hedonia where things don't delight us. We fail to experience the full delight of life. Dyshthymia is quite prevalent. It's very prevalent in young people. If we don't like our job, if we haven't found our deeper path, dyshthymia is a low-grade depression that lingers and lingers. and even becomes livable. So it becomes a normal low-grade pain or disengagement. I mean, in some ways, you were seeing it on the subway.
它是什么意思？心境恶劣是一种低级的、恼人的、萦绕心头的……有点像那种平淡无奇的灰色抑郁。这是一种不满和快感缺失，事物无法让我们感到愉悦。我们无法体验到生活的全部乐趣。心境恶劣非常普遍。它在年轻人中非常普遍。如果我们不喜欢我们的工作，如果我们没有找到更深层的道路，心境恶劣就是一种挥之不去的低级抑郁。甚至变得可以忍受。所以它变成了一种正常的低级痛苦或疏离。我的意思是，在某种程度上，你在地铁上看到了它。
You were seeing it at your dinner parties with your friends. Yes. It's very easy to try to override the emptiness of dysaimia through a promotion or a new apartment or a vacation. But disfaymiya runs deeper than the outward markers of achievement in the monopoly game. Dyshthymia is, you could say, a hole in the heart, a hole in the soul. It is a yearning for a deeper connection in life.
你在和朋友的晚宴上也看到了它。是的。试图通过晋升、新公寓或度假来覆盖心境恶劣的空虚是非常容易的。但心境恶劣比“大富翁”游戏中外在的成就标志更深。心境恶劣，你可以说，是心中的一个洞，灵魂里的一个洞。它是对生活中更深层连接的渴望。
In her work with patients and in her own social world, Lisa was seeing that the conventional approaches to achieving a good life were falling short. When we come back, exploring possibilities that lie beyond the material and the practical. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Modern science has given us astonishing tools to map the brain, sequence the genome, and analyze the body's chemistry.
在与病人的工作和她自己的社交世界中，丽莎看到实现美好生活的传统方法正在失效。当我们回来时，我们将探索超越物质和实际的可能性。你正在收听《Hidden Brain》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这是《Hidden Brain》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。现代科学为我们提供了惊人的工具来绘制大脑图谱、测序基因组并分析身体的化学成分。
Many scientists interpret these advances as proof that life is nothing more than matter in motion. At Teachers College Columbia University, psychologist Lisa Miller is interested in the possibility that the human brain is built to have a spiritual dimension to it. For many years now, she has deployed scientific methods to study this aspect of the mind. Lisa, both your psychological training and the culture at large
许多科学家将这些进步解释为生命不过是运动中的物质的证据。在哥伦比亚大学师范学院，心理学家丽莎·米勒对人类大脑天生具有精神维度的可能性很感兴趣。多年来，她一直运用科学方法来研究心灵的这一方面。丽莎，你的心理学训练和整个文化
gave you a model of human existence, a notion that we're all just billiard balls bouncing off each other. Unpacked this metaphor for me. Shankar, coming through graduate school, Training as an intern, I learned the models of the time for treatment of depression, treatment of anxiety. We're really radical materialist models, which means that the brain is effectively an atomistically sealed brain, like a brain in the box. The depression had biological correlates that needed to be treated with medicine, but also that psychotherapy. silent on spirituality,
给了你一种人类存在的模型，一种认为我们都只是互相碰撞的台球的观念。为我拆解一下这个隐喻。尚卡尔，在研究生院学习，作为实习生接受训练时，我学习了当时治疗抑郁症、治疗焦虑症的模型。它们确实是激进的唯物主义模型，这意味着大脑实际上是一个原子式密封的大脑，就像盒子里的脑子。抑郁症有需要用药物治疗的生物学相关性，但也认为心理治疗——
reworking life experience, would also shift, and there was evidence of this, shift the brain. But spirituality, spiritually infused religion, was viewed as something outside of the medical establishment. It was separate from the biology
重塑生活经验——也会改变大脑，而且有证据表明确实如此。但灵性，充满灵性的宗教，被视为医学机构之外的东西。它与生物学
or the neural mechanisms of the human condition. And so what I had witnessed on Unit 6 in the hospital, on the inpatient unit in New York City, said to me, you know, the spiritual life is part of the same person who is recovering from depression because the illumination was so strong. So I set sail for 30 years of science, MRI studies, long-term clinical course studies, epidemi studies, epidemiological studies, genotyping studies, you name it, any lens or a set of collaborators with whom I could work, to ask the question, where is spiritual awareness in the composition of the whole person?
或人类状况的神经机制是分开的。所以我在纽约市医院6号病房、住院部所目睹的一切告诉我：“你知道，精神生活是那个正在从抑郁中恢复的人的一部分，因为那种光芒太强烈了。”所以我开始了30年的科学探索，核磁共振研究、长期临床过程研究、流行病学研究、基因分型研究，你能想到的任何镜头或与我合作的一组合作者，来问这个问题：在整个人的构成中，精神觉知在哪里？
And how might spiritual awareness be healing and even protective against the most prevalent forms of suffering? What I find fascinating about your work, Lisa, is that you are trying to marry together these two parts of yourself. you're interested in the world of transcendence, and you're also interested in scientific measurement, and you're trying to understand this dimension of our lives using scientific techniques. One of the dimensions of your research has linked spiritual experience to specific neuroanatomical and neurophysiological markers. Tell me a little bit about this work. So, Shankar, just as there are neural correlates for depression or anxiety,
精神觉知如何能够治愈，甚至能够预防最普遍的痛苦形式？丽莎，你的工作让我着迷的是，你正试图将你自己的这两个部分结合在一起。你对超越性的世界感兴趣，你也对科学测量感兴趣，你正试图用科学技术来理解我们生活的这个维度。你研究的维度之一是将精神体验与特定的神经解剖学和神经生理学标记联系起来。跟我谈谈这项工作。所以，尚卡尔，就像抑郁症或焦虑症有神经相关性一样，
is there's neuro-correlates for hunger or craving or thirst, it turns out that there are neural correlates for spiritual awareness. Now, if you think about it, it would seem to make sense that we all have a common visual system. We all have a common auditory system through which to perceive. And it turns out through now 15 years of MRI studies, we all have a common set of circuits through which to perceive the transcendent. Now, it doesn't matter if I am Hindu or Jane or Jewish or Muslim or Catholic or Christian or spiritual and not religious. We all share the same core neural circuits of transcendent awareness. Of course, as in any form of perception, there's human variability in the intensity or in the nuance with which we experience perception.
就像饥饿、渴望或口渴有神经相关性一样，事实证明，精神觉知也有神经相关性。现在，如果你仔细想想，我们都有一个共同的视觉系统，我们都有一个共同的听觉系统来感知，这似乎是有道理的。事实证明，通过现在15年的核磁共振研究，我们都有一个共同的回路集来感知超越性。现在，无论我是印度教徒、耆那教徒、犹太教徒、穆斯林、天主教徒、基督徒，还是有灵性但没有宗教信仰，这都无关紧要。我们都共享感知超越性的核心神经回路。当然，正如任何形式的感知一样，我们在感知体验的强度或细微差别上存在人类差异。
Shankar, what's extraordinary is that perception of the transcendent calls on the same neurocircuits, no matter what tradition I may be, or even if I am spiritual, but not religious. What are those circuits? Well, there are four. The first and only the first is associated with quieting the mind. It's shared, of course, with mindfulness, the disengagement of the default mode network, the racket that spins round and round. But mindfulness, as helpful as it is to bringing us present, presence alone is not sufficient for transcendent awareness.
尚卡尔，非凡之处在于，对超越性的感知调用了相同的神经回路，无论我是什么传统，甚至如果我是有灵性但没有宗教信仰的人。那些回路是什么？嗯，有四个。第一个，也仅仅是第一个，与让心灵平静有关。它当然与正念共享，即默认模式网络的脱离，那个不断旋转的噪音。但正念，尽管它对让我们处于当下很有帮助，但仅仅有“当下”不足以产生超越性觉知。
Presence is perhaps the threshold of the door through which we might then cross to experience transcendent awareness. And there are three circuits on the other side of the door seen in all people of all faith traditions at a moment of transcendent connection. First, the bonding network comes up online. The same bonding network engaged when we are babies and our parents or grandparents' arms through which we feel and know that we are loved and held. The universe, God, Hashem, Allah, Jesus, whatever one's sacred word, loves and holds us. We are absolutely held. That is not a belief. That is a perception. It is a felt perception. The second circuit to come online is attentional. We see a shift from the very narrow, top-down dorsal attention. Why did I say that? What's going to happen next? Am I going to get fired? Did the check bounce? What could I have done differently? The narrow assumption of radical control, what do I want? How do I want? How I'm going to get fired? Do the check bounce? What could I have done differently? The narrow assumption? How do I want?
“当下”也许是那扇门的门槛，我们或许可以穿过它去体验超越性觉知。在门的那一边，有三个回路，在所有信仰传统的人身上，在超越性连接的时刻都能看到。首先，联结网络上线了。当我们还是婴儿，在父母或祖父母怀里时，我们通过它感受并知道我们是被爱和被拥抱的。宇宙、上帝、哈希姆、安拉、耶稣，无论一个人的神圣词汇是什么，都在爱着并拥抱我们。我们绝对是被拥抱的。那不是一种信仰。那是一种感知。这是一种被感受到的感知。第二个上线的回路是注意力的。我们看到从非常狭窄的、自上而下的背侧注意力发生了转变。为什么我那样说？接下来会发生什么？我会不会被解雇？支票会跳票吗？我本可以做些什么不同的事情？那种对激进控制的狭隘假设——我想要什么？我怎么想要？我怎么会被解雇？支票会跳票吗？我本可以做些什么不同的事情？那种狭隘的假设——我想要什么？
going to get it, yields and gives way to the ventral attention network where suddenly the lights come back on. There's a broad linescape before us, and we ask, what is life showing me now? At which moment many people say a new direction pops, a door never seen before opens, an inspired sense of guidance. We are loved and held. We are guided. We are guided. And third, we are loved and held, we are guided. And the parietal that puts in and out hard boundaries that lets us know, Shankar, that you sit in one city and I sit in a sister city, that we each have our exquisitely beautiful, diverse biobody suits. We have different GPS coordinates. We are a point and we are a wave.
怎么得到它——屈服并让位于腹侧注意力网络，突然间灯光重新亮起。我们面前有一个广阔的景观，我们问：“生命现在在向我展示什么？”在这一刻，许多人说一个新的方向出现了，一扇从未见过的门打开了，一种灵感的指引感。我们被爱和拥抱。我们被引导。我们被引导。第三，我们被爱和拥抱，我们被引导。还有顶叶，它设定了硬边界，它让我们知道，尚卡尔，你坐在一个城市，我坐在另一个城市，我们每个人都有我们精致美丽、多样的生物身体套装。我们有不同的GPS坐标。我们是一个点，我们也是一个波。
We are distinct and beautifully diverse. And we are part of one unit of whole, one family of life. loved, held, guided, and never alone. Loved held guided and never alone moves together. These three circuits move together. It's not that we're loved, but we're not guided, or we're guided, but we're not. The awakened brain moves together with these three circuits. Everyone on Earth has the capacity to be in a deep, transcendent relationship
我们是独特的，美丽多样的。我们是整体的一个单位，生命大家庭的一部分。被爱、被拥抱、被引导，永远不孤单。被爱、被拥抱、被引导，永远不孤单，它们一起移动。这三个回路一起移动。并不是说我们被爱但没有被引导，或者我们被引导但没有被爱。觉醒的大脑与这三个回路一起移动。地球上的每个人都有能力处于一种深刻的、超越性的关系中，
through which they know the deeper force in life. I understand that in your brain imaging, studies, you find changes in cortical thickness in people who are especially spiritual? Every human being on earth is born with a natural capacity for spiritual awareness. We know this through twin studies. We can look at twins raised together, twins raised apart, and factor out commonalities of function of shared environment, shared genes. So, for instance, temperament is about half innate, half environmentally four. IQ is about two-thirds innate, one-third environmentally formed.
通过这种关系，他们了解生命中更深层的力量。我了解到，在你的大脑成像研究中，你发现特别有灵性的人大脑皮层厚度发生了变化？地球上的每个人生来就具有精神觉知的自然能力。我们通过双胞胎研究知道了这一点。我们可以观察一起长大的双胞胎、分开长大的双胞胎，并剔除功能和共享环境、共享基因的共性。所以，例如，气质大约一半是先天的，一半是环境形成的。智商大约三分之二是先天的，三分之一是环境形成的。
The capacity through which we experience transcendent relationship is innate. It is one-third innate. Every single one of us is born with the natural neurocircuits for transcendent awareness. But one-third innate, two-thirds environmentally formed, means that our parents and grandparents, the 10,000 exchanges at school, our pastor-priest-a-man rabbi, our relationship to nature. And as we get older, we choose our environment, both outer, the company we keep, the service that we offer or not to our world, and the inner environment, whether I meditate, whether I pray, whether I reflect or read sacred transcendent text, two-thirds environmentally formed
我们体验超越性关系的这种能力是先天的。它是三分之一先天的。我们每个人生来就拥有超越性觉知的自然神经回路。但三分之一先天、三分之二环境形成，意味着我们的父母和祖父母、学校里的10,000次交流、我们的牧师、神父、拉比、我们与自然的关系。随着我们年龄的增长，我们选择我们的环境，包括外部环境——我们结交的朋友、我们为世界提供的服务（或不提供），以及内部环境——我是否冥想、我是否祈祷、我是否反思或阅读神圣的超越性文本。三分之二环境形成
means that, yes, we are all naturally spiritual beings, but we have the opportunity of our lifetime to cultivate our spiritual awareness. When we do, we see literally a thicker cortex across the regions of the awakened brain. Sustained spiritual life, prayer, meditation, service, right action, often within a faith community, often service outside a faith community. sustained spiritual life is associated with cortical thickness across the regions of the awakened brain. Now, by sustained spiritual life in this study, which we published in JAMA psychiatry, we looked over eight years. People who sustained a strong spiritual life who said my personal spiritual life is highly important to me. Over eight years showed a thicker cortex across the regions of the awakened brain.
意味着，是的，我们都是天生的精神存在，但我们拥有终生的机会来培养我们的精神觉知。当我们这样做时，我们确实看到了觉醒大脑区域的皮层变厚了。持续的精神生活——祈祷、冥想、服务、正确的行动，通常在信仰社区内，通常在信仰社区外服务——持续的精神生活与觉醒大脑区域的皮层厚度有关。现在，通过这项我们在《美国医学会杂志·精神病学》上发表的研究中提到的“持续精神生活”，我们观察了八年。那些维持强有力精神生活的人，那些说“我的个人精神生活对我来说非常重要”的人，在八年里显示出觉醒大脑区域的皮层更厚。
Shankar, what makes this particularly helpful as we think back to Unit 6 is that when we sustain our spiritual life, the cortical thickness is seen across the regions, the very same regions, that are not thick but thin, in people with recurrent major depression. People with sustained spiritual lives show cortical thickness across the very same regions that are not thick but thin if we're. We are struggling with recurrent major depression, which is to say that spirituality and depression appear to be two sides of one coin. I'm wondering, as you have presented these ideas, how they've been received by your colleagues. You told me that when you talked with your supervisor back in the day, your supervisor said, it's nice that you helped the patients by performing a religious service, but this is not something to put on your resume.
尚卡尔，当我们回想6号病房时，这特别有帮助，因为当我们维持我们的精神生活时，皮层厚度出现在各个区域，正是那些在反复发作重度抑郁症的人身上不厚反而变薄的区域。拥有持续精神生活的人在觉醒大脑区域显示出皮层厚度，而这些区域在如果我们正在与反复发作的重度抑郁症作斗争时，是不厚反而变薄的。也就是说，灵性和抑郁症似乎是同一枚硬币的两面。我想知道，当你提出这些想法时，你的同事们是如何接受它们的？你告诉我，当你当年和你的主管交谈时，你的主管说：“你通过举行宗教仪式帮助了病人，这很好，但这不是写在简历上的东西。”
This is not something to talk about because this in some ways is antithetical to what we're doing here. We're supposed to be scientists. We're supposed to be medical practitioners. I'm wondering how, as you have accumulated this body of research in the course of your career, how it's been received by your colleagues. When I saw the tremendous impact of spiritual life on ameliorating, on breaking through some forms of suffering and despair, I raised the lens of science because the language of science and in fact the facts of science are the foundation of medically based mental health. And of course the second reason I've always loved science is because it is jaw-droppingly spectacular to look through the lens of science. So Shankar, I started publishing in a way that I have.
“这不是谈论的东西，因为这在某种程度上与我们在这里所做的事情背道而驰。我们应该是科学家。我们应该是医疗从业者。”我想知道，随着你在职业生涯中积累了这些研究成果，你的同事们是如何接受它们的。当我看到精神生活在改善、突破某些形式的痛苦和绝望方面的巨大影响时，我提高了科学的镜头，因为科学的语言，事实上科学的事实，是基于医学的心理健康的基础。当然，我一直热爱科学的第二个原因是，通过科学的镜头观察是令人瞠目结舌的壮观。所以尚卡尔，我开始以一种我
hoped would speak to the field because out of every 10 variables in an article, nine of them were familiar. I used very tried and true beloved top-nutch data sets. I drew on the variables and the measures that everyone else in the top peer review journals used. I set up the design that was familiar to people. And having effectively replicated nine out of 10 elements of a study, I added one variable, which was how personally important is spirituality or religion to you. And over time, that item expanded into scales and measures of spiritual life. But I always added one and only one variable, what is the nature of your spiritual life, to a study that otherwise looked very familiar. And in this way, we were able to publish in top peer review journals.
希望能够与该领域对话的方式发表文章，因为在一篇文章的每10个变量中，有9个是熟悉的。我使用了非常久经考验、备受推崇的顶级数据集。我利用了顶级同行评审期刊中其他人使用的变量和衡量标准。我设置了人们熟悉的设计。在有效地复制了研究的十分之九的要素后，我增加了一个变量，即“灵性或宗教对你个人有多重要”。随着时间的推移，该项目扩展为精神生活的量表和衡量标准。但我总是增加一个且仅增加一个变量——你的精神生活的本质是什么——到一项在其他方面看起来非常熟悉的研究中。通过这种方式，我们能够在顶级同行评审期刊上发表文章。
the American Academy of Child and Adolescent Psychiatry, American Journal of Psychiatry, JAMA psychiatry, because the studies had the blue housekeeping seal of all the markers that we had come to trust as a field. Reliable measures, familiar statistics, dotted eyes, cross-tees, everything was meticulous,
《美国儿童和青少年精神病学学会》、《美国精神病学杂志》、《美国医学会杂志·精神病学》，因为这些研究拥有我们作为一个领域已经开始信任的所有标记的“蓝色家政印章”。可靠的衡量标准、熟悉的统计数据、一丝不苟，一切都非常细致，
and in keeping with the field, except for the step of advance spiritual life. every single article, as you know Shankar, is submitted for peer review. Peer review is conducted blind to who the authors are, so there's no sort of cult of personality or vogue or one lab over another. And science also, in the peer review process, requires that two or three scientists within or closely adjacent to the area of inquiry, weigh in on the method, weigh in on the conclusions, offer recommendations for expansion. of the study. We were able over now three decades to publish our lab, often in collaboration with fellow labs, about 200 peer review articles and chapters, and the field around us has grown. We've tried to be collaborators in building a field as well. But I will tell you, Shankar,
并且与该领域保持一致，除了“高级精神生活”这一步。每一篇文章，正如你所知尚卡尔，都要提交同行评审。同行评审是在对作者身份保密的情况下进行的，所以没有那种个人崇拜或时尚，也没有一个实验室优于另一个实验室的情况。科学在同行评审过程中也要求两三位在研究领域内或紧密相关的科学家对方法进行权衡，对结论进行权衡，并提供扩展研究的建议。在过去的三十年里，我们的实验室，通常与合作实验室一起，发表了大约200篇同行评审文章和章节，我们周围的领域也成长起来了。我们也试图成为建立该领域的合作者。但我会告诉你，尚卡尔，
that despite the meticulous science and top peer review journals, because the findings were new, I would say people did not know yet what to do with these new scientific findings. And so, for instance, we published an article that showed that an adolescent with a strong spiritual life compared to one who doesn't really know what you're talking about was 80% protective against onset of addiction. 80% protective, who wouldn't want that for their child? And yet when I presented these findings published in the top journal for children and adolescents, there was an utter silence and confusion. A couple people left. They got up and walked out in the middle of grand rounds later to share, well, what does that have to do with mental health?
尽管有细致的科学和顶级同行评审期刊，但因为这些发现是新的，我会说人们还不知道如何处理这些新的科学发现。例如，我们发表了一篇文章，显示与一个不知道你在说什么的青少年相比，拥有强有力精神生活的青少年对成瘾发作有80%的保护作用。80%的保护作用，谁不希望自己的孩子拥有这一点呢？然而，当我展示这些发表在儿童和青少年顶级期刊上的发现时，却是一片死寂和困惑。几个人离开了。他们站起来，在查房中途走开了，后来分享说：“嗯，这和心理健康有什么关系？”
What does that have to do with psychology? But most people were just confused. The paradigm at the time didn't have a place for what on earth is. going on. And so, you know, good people, good healers were confused and a lot of this just sort of, you know, dropped silence for a while. And then culture started to change. New residents came, new psychologists came. And in the rising generation, there was more curiosity and perhaps a stronger sense of personal spiritual quest. And I saw residents light up, oh, wow, you want to talk about spirituality? or to sign a book or offer an article in the room felt liberated. The rising generation wanted to talk about spirituality and felt free. There were plenty of good spiritual people who were senior, but perhaps didn't feel free to speak their heart about spirituality.
“这和心理学有什么关系？”但大多数人只是感到困惑。当时的范式对于到底发生了什么没有位置。所以，你知道，好人、好的治疗师感到困惑，很多东西就只是，你知道，沉默了一段时间。然后文化开始改变。新的住院医生来了，新的心理学家来了。在成长中的一代人中，有更多的好奇心，或许有一种更强烈的个人精神追求感。我看到住院医生们眼睛亮了起来，“哦，哇，你想谈论灵性？”或者在房间里签名或提供一篇文章，感觉如释重负。成长中的一代人想谈论灵性，并感到自由。有很多优秀的、资深的精神性人士，但他们可能觉得不能自由地表达他们对灵性的内心感受。
I'm wondering, Lisa, whether some of the resistance comes from the fact that there are many claims that people make about religion and spirituality that, in fact, are not scientific, claims. Many people who are making claims on behalf of religion or spirituality have not done the empirical work that you have done. And so perhaps there's a knee-jerk reaction among scientists to say anything that smacks of spirituality must by definition not be scientific. You know, Shankar, one of the most important findings was put forward in 1997, replicated in 1999 by Ken Kempler. at Virginia Commonwealth. And what Kenler identified was that spirituality is innate. It is one-third innate, two-thirds environmentally formed.
丽莎，我想知道，这种抵触情绪是否来自这样一个事实：人们对宗教和灵性提出的许多主张，事实上并不是科学的主张。许多代表宗教或灵性提出主张的人并没有做过你所做的实证工作。所以，科学家们可能有一种膝跳反应，认为任何带有灵性色彩的东西在定义上一定是不科学的。你知道，尚卡尔，最重要的发现之一是在1997年提出的，并于1999年由肯·肯普勒在弗吉尼亚联邦大学复制。肯普勒确定的是，灵性是先天的。它是三分之一先天的，三分之二环境形成的。
Religion is environmentally transmitted, almost entirely. So there's enormous confusion in a country where for 40 years there has effectively been an ice age on spiritual and religious discourse in the public square. where people in the classroom or boardroom or at a dinner party don't know how to talk about spiritual, a religious life without imposing or don't know where the line is. There's a tendency to simply shut down. So in that context, I have found in the 10 years I've spent sharing the science on spiritual life, resilience, and mental health, I have seen enormous confusion, Shankar, over the difference between spirituality and religion. Through the lens of science, religion is a gift of our parents and grandparents. We might choose a faith tradition and immerse ourselves.
宗教是环境传播的，几乎完全是。所以在一个国家里存在巨大的困惑，因为40年来，公共广场上的精神和宗教话语实际上一直处于冰河时代。在教室、董事会或晚宴上，人们不知道如何在不强加于人的情况下谈论精神、宗教生活，或者不知道界限在哪里。有一种简单地关闭话语的倾向。因此，在这种背景下，在我分享关于精神生活、韧性和心理健康的科学的10年里，我看到了巨大的困惑，尚卡尔，关于灵性和宗教之间的区别。通过科学的镜头，宗教是我们父母和祖父母的礼物。我们可以选择一种信仰传统并沉浸其中。
Religion is environmentally transmitted. Spirituality is innate. The capacity for a transcendent relationship as tracked by discrete and specific neural circuits that are universal in every human brain. So now when I'm asked, hey, what about the fact that people have done all these bad things in the name of religion, I can say, well, my question as a scientist is, are they acting in a way that is consistent with natural spirituality? Is this person conducting themselves in such a way that is consistent with being loving, guiding, and never leaving anyone alone? alone. So if I hear a comment, hey, wait a minute, how can you say spirituality is so good when all these bad things have been done in the name of religion, I say, well, is the practice of that so-called religion consistent with natural spirituality? Are they being loving, guiding, and not
宗教是环境传播的，而灵性是与生俱来的。正如离散且特定的神经回路所追踪的那样，超越性关系的潜能是每个人类大脑中普遍存在的。所以现在当有人问我，嘿，人们以宗教的名义做了这么多坏事，你怎么看？我可以回答，作为一名科学家，我的问题是，他们的行为是否符合自然灵性？此人的行为是否符合充满爱、引导且从不让任何人感到孤独的原则？所以，如果我听到有人评论说，嘿，等等，既然以宗教名义做了这么多坏事，你怎么能说灵性是好的呢？我会说，那么，那种所谓的宗教实践是否符合自然灵性？他们是否在表现出爱、引导，并且不
leaving anyone alone? When we come back, what science shows us about the effects of spirituality on our mental and physical health. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Have you had experiences in your life when you felt helped or hindered by your own spirituality? If you have a personal story that you would be willing to share with the Hidden Brain audience or a question or comment about Lisa Miller's research, please find a very quiet room and record a voice memo on your phone. Two or three minutes is plenty. Email the file to us at Feedback at HiddenBrain.org using the subject line, spiritual. Again, that's Feedback at Hidden Brain.org. Lisa Miller is the author of the
让任何人感到孤独？稍后回来，我们将探讨科学如何揭示灵性对我们身心健康的影响。您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。在您的生活中，是否有过因为自己的灵性而感到被帮助或受阻的经历？如果您有一个愿意与《隐藏的大脑》听众分享的个人故事，或者对丽莎·米勒的研究有任何问题或评论，请找一个非常安静的房间，在手机上录制一段语音备忘录。两三分钟就足够了。请将文件通过电子邮件发送至 Feedback@HiddenBrain.org，主题行请注明“spiritual”。再次重申，地址是 Feedback@HiddenBrain.org。丽莎·米勒是《觉醒的大脑》一书的作者，
awakened brain, the new science of spirituality and our quest for an inspired life. Lisa, you found that an engagement with a personal spirituality is associated with improved stress, resilience, and faster physiological recovery. How do you think spirituality protects us against the psychological and physiological effects of stress? There are multiple pathways through which spirituality protects us against physical and mental illness. First off, the most remarkable finding in science is the scale, the magnitude at which spirituality protects against some of the most prevalent forms of suffering. The number one cause of death right now to rival auto accidents is suicide in Gen Z in high school and college.
该书探讨了灵性的新科学以及我们对灵感生活的追求。丽莎，你发现参与个人灵性活动与改善压力、增强韧性以及更快的生理恢复有关。你认为灵性是如何保护我们免受压力带来的心理和生理影响的？灵性保护我们免受身心疾病侵害的途径有很多。首先，科学界最引人注目的发现是灵性在保护我们免受某些最普遍的痛苦方面的规模和程度。目前，Z世代高中生和大学生中，仅次于车祸的头号死因是自杀。
A strong personal life when shared, shared in the Sanga, the Mingyan, the fellowship amongst friends or family, is 82% protective against completed suicides, four-fists less likely to take our life. So if I told you, Shankar, there's a little pill. And you can pick up this little pill at Walgreens or the CVS at the drugstore, and it will protect your child, your grandchild, all the students in your classroom, four fists against the leading cause of morbidity, of death in young people. Who wouldn't give that to their child? I understand that you and others have found that having a spiritual side to one's life is associated with greater well-being and life satisfaction.
当个人生活在僧伽（Sanga）、明言（Mingyan）或朋友与家人间的友谊中被分享时，这种强大的个人生活对预防自杀有82%的保护作用，自杀的可能性降低了五分之四。所以，如果我告诉你，尚卡尔，有一种小药丸，你可以在沃尔格林或CVS药店买到，它能保护你的孩子、孙辈以及教室里的所有学生，使其免受年轻人头号致死原因的侵害，比例高达五分之四，谁会不给自己的孩子服用呢？我理解你和其他人发现，生活中拥有灵性的一面与更高的幸福感和生活满意度有关。
Do you think this is connected to those three things you talked about earlier that people with a spiritual side feel like they are held, that they're guided, that they are nurtured? Precisely, we walk on an entirely different landscape. We walk on sacred landscape when we open the aperture and let in the light through our awakened brain. Life unfolds in an entirely different way. Life moves from what do I want and how am I going to get it?
你认为这与你之前提到的那三件事有关吗？即拥有灵性一面的人会感到自己被支持、被引导、被滋养？正是如此，我们走在完全不同的景观上。当我们打开光圈，让光线通过我们觉醒的大脑照进来时，我们走在神圣的景观上。生活以完全不同的方式展开。生活从“我想要什么以及我将如何得到它”转变为
Really quite a transactional way of life. And by the way, who are you? How are you going to help me get what I want? Relationships of transactions. What I call narrow achieving awareness. Out of that narrow rut to, hey, okay, I just didn't get what I wanted. I didn't get the job. My kid didn't get into the college.
一种非常交易式的生活方式。顺便问一下，你是谁？你将如何帮助我得到我想要的？这是交易关系。我称之为狭隘的成就意识。走出那个狭隘的死胡同，去面对：嘿，好吧，我只是没得到我想要的。我没得到那份工作。我的孩子没被那所大学录取。
Hey, what is life showing? me now. We move from what do I want and how am I going to get it and what did I do wrong? How could I get it next time to wait a minute. What is life showing me now? What is the universe directing? What am I being asked to do? Am I being asked to love more deeply? Am I being asked to listen to those with whom I work or my children? Am I being given an opportunity to serve? The life that is before us, is so much bigger and full of portals and possibilities than we could a priori have spun or cooked up in our mind. In other words, when we can release the stranglehold of our expectations and plans and be less hard core makers of our path, creating space to be discoverers of our journey, life unfolds in extraordinary ways.
嘿，生活现在在向我展示什么？我们从“我想要什么，我该如何得到它，我做错了什么，下次我该如何得到它”转变为“等等，生活现在在向我展示什么？宇宙在指引什么？我被要求做什么？我是否被要求更深地去爱？我是否被要求倾听与我共事的人或我的孩子？我是否得到了服务的机会？”我们面前的生活，比我们预先在脑海中构想或编造的要宏大得多，充满了门户和可能性。换句话说，当我们能够释放对期望和计划的束缚，不再做路径的死板制造者，而是为成为旅程的探索者创造空间时，生活就会以非凡的方式展开。
It is beyond what we might have imagined. In other words, when I can move from narrow achieving awareness to open up a relationship, a dialogue with life, I can be guided in places I didn't even know existed. I can find a job that I didn't even know was a job. I can meet someone at a party that I wouldn't have spoken to because they didn't meet my A prior criteria of a date. but if I'm open, why is the universe introducing me to this person now? I can discover a relationship I've never dreamed of. That's a much bigger life. That is an inspired life.
它超出了我们可能想象的范围。换句话说，当我能从狭隘的成就意识转变为与生活建立开放的关系和对话时，我可以在我甚至不知道存在的地方得到引导。我可以找到一份我甚至不知道是工作的工作。我可以在聚会上遇到一个我本来不会交谈的人，因为他们不符合我预先设定的约会标准。但如果我保持开放，为什么宇宙现在要把这个人介绍给我？我可以发现一段我从未梦想过的关系。那是一个更广阔的生活。那是一种充满灵感的生活。
So Lisa, you've made a couple of references in this conversation to the distinction between an achievement-oriented brain and an awakened brain. Can you talk about this distinction for a moment? it's a central portion of your research career these past few decades. Shankar, every one of us has a capacity for two types of reasoning. On the one hand, we have achieving awareness, the ability for strategizing, tactic, research, empiricism. Achieving awareness is extremely helpful at laying out a plan.
所以丽莎，你在这次谈话中几次提到了成就导向的大脑和觉醒的大脑之间的区别。你能谈谈这个区别吗？这是你过去几十年来研究生涯的核心部分。尚卡尔，我们每个人都有两种推理能力。一方面，我们有成就意识，即制定战略、战术、研究和经验主义的能力。成就意识在制定计划时非常有帮助。
And we come to achieving awareness with a great deal of practice. We learned in school. You're the first thing I ever received on my desk in first grade. Right there in the center of my first grade desk was a planner. In school, I learned to plan, to organize, to some extent, to control. Achieve an awareness has tremendous instrumental value. It helps us pay the rent. Achieving awareness helps us move through a scientific problem.
我们通过大量的练习来获得成就意识。我们在学校里学到了这一点。这是我在一年级时收到的第一件东西。就在我一年级课桌的中央，放着一个计划本。在学校里，我学会了计划、组织，在某种程度上，学会了控制。成就意识具有巨大的工具价值。它帮助我们支付房租。成就意识帮助我们解决科学问题。
achieving awareness alone is utterly insufficient for a meaningful life. Achieving awareness will get us on the A train and it might send us flying at great speeds, but when we disembark, we may not even know where we are. This is what we learn in school, how to do. But we all are also endowed with another form of perception. Our natural Awakened Awareness. Awakened awareness is the capacity to perceive through intuition, perhaps a mystical experience. Awakened awareness is a receptive form of perception. Awakened awareness asks the question, what is life showing me now?
仅靠成就意识对于有意义的生活是完全不够的。成就意识会让我们登上A列车，它可能会让我们以极高的速度飞驰，但当我们下车时，我们甚至可能不知道自己在哪里。这就是我们在学校里学到的东西。但我们每个人也被赋予了另一种感知形式。我们自然的觉醒意识。觉醒意识是通过直觉感知的能力，也许是一种神秘的体验。觉醒意识是一种接受性的感知形式。觉醒意识会问这样一个问题：生活现在在向我展示什么？
What did I just perceive? That whisper of a hunch? We need both. Awaken Awareness sets our North Star. Awakened Awareness sets our true direction. Achieving awareness rolls out the plan, how to get there. The problem in our contemporary culture is that very often we are highly versed in practiced in achieving awareness, but we don't know where we're going because we've yet to find our guiding star through our awakened awareness.
我刚刚感知到了什么？那低语般的预感？我们需要两者兼备。觉醒意识设定了我们的北极星。觉醒意识设定了我们真正的方向。成就意识制定了计划，即如何到达那里。我们当代文化的问题在于，我们往往非常精通和练习成就意识，但我们不知道我们要去哪里，因为我们还没有通过觉醒意识找到我们的指路明灯。
Lisa Miller is a psychologist at Teachers College College College. Columbia University. She's the author of The Awakened Brain, the new science of spirituality, and our quest for an inspired life. Lisa, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. What a joy, Shankar, I so enjoyed connecting with you. Thank you. Have you had experiences in your life when you felt helped or hindered by your own spirituality? If you have a personal story that you would be willing to share with the Hidden Brain audience, or a question or comment about Lisa Miller's research, please find a very quiet room and record a voice memo on your phone. Two or three minutes is plenty.
丽莎·米勒是哥伦比亚大学师范学院的心理学家。她是《觉醒的大脑：灵性的新科学与我们对灵感生活的追求》一书的作者。丽莎，非常感谢你今天参加《隐藏的大脑》。真高兴，尚卡尔，我非常享受与你的交流。谢谢。在你的生活中，是否有过因为自己的灵性而感到被帮助或受阻的经历？如果你有一个愿意与《隐藏的大脑》听众分享的个人故事，或者对丽莎·米勒的研究有任何问题或评论，请找一个非常安静的房间，在手机上录制一段语音备忘录。两三分钟就足够了。
Email the file to us at Feedback at HiddenBrain.org using the subject line, spiritual. Again, that's Feedback at Hiddenbrain.org. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Querell, Ryan Katz, Orrumb Barnes, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brains executive editor. Our unsung hero today is Pablo Voight Thaler. Pablo is a video and digital media producer at Stanford University.
请将文件通过电子邮件发送至 Feedback@HiddenBrain.org，主题行请注明“spiritual”。再次重申，地址是 Feedback@HiddenBrain.org。《隐藏的大脑》由《隐藏的大脑》媒体制作。我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲·保罗、克里斯汀·王、劳拉·奎雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、奥鲁姆·巴恩斯、安德鲁·查德威克和尼克·伍德伯里。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行编辑。我们今天的无名英雄是巴勃罗·沃伊特·塔勒。巴勃罗是斯坦福大学的视频和数字媒体制作人。
A few weeks ago, I was at Stanford for a stop on Hidden Brains live tour. I needed to record some audio for the show, and Pablo helped me out at a studio at the Stanford Business School. Thank you, Pablo. If you enjoyed this episode, please be sure. sure to share it with a friend or a family member. You never know who might find the ideas in an episode like this valuable at a difficult point in their lives. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
几周前，我在斯坦福参加《隐藏的大脑》现场巡演。我需要为节目录制一些音频，巴勃罗在斯坦福商学院的工作室里帮了我。谢谢你，巴勃罗。如果你喜欢这一集，请务必与朋友或家人分享。你永远不知道谁会在人生的困难时刻发现这一集中的观点很有价值。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。再见。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。